بعد أكثر من 15 شهرًا ، عادت أول
سفينة سياحية أمريكية
إلى البحر على حافة المشاهير المتبقية من فورت
لودرديل فلوريدا في نهاية هذا الأسبوع
وللحفاظ على سلامة الجميع ،
قام الطاقم بعمل
قائمة بالتغييرات ، لذا فهم
أوقات وصول مذهلة.  بالنسبة لموظفي الانتظار
لإحضار الطعام بدلاً من جعل الضيوف
يصعدون إلى البوفيه ،
هناك أيضًا أربعة أسرّة العناية المركزة على متن الطائرة
، وهنا الشيء الآخر هناك 95
بالمائة من الركاب الذين تم تطعيمهم
وأولئك الذين لم يتم تطعيمهم أو
الذين لم يقولوا  إذا تم تطعيمهم ،
يُطلب منهم ارتداء
أقنعة في الأماكن العامة ،
فيجب عليهم أيضًا اختبار فيروس
كوفيد وهذا على نفقتهم الخاصة ، فإن ناتاشا
تشن على متن الطائرة
مع أفضل مهمة في الأسبوع
ويتني ولورا من نواح كثيرة ، وهذا أمر
نموذجي  تجربة الرحلات البحرية ، لقد حصلت على
الكازينو
الذي لديك متاجر مجوهرات ، ولكن هناك
علامات تدل على الإبحار في عصر الوباء ، حيث توجد
محطات مطهر لليدين في كل مكان ،
ونسمع أيضًا
الفرقة الموجودة في الخلفية.
انظر حولك إلى الطاولات على الرغم
من عدم وجود الكثير من الأشخاص ، ولا حشود
متجمعة
، وذلك لأن هذه الرحلة البحرية
تبحر بسعة لا تزيد عن 40 في المائة ، وقد
تم تطعيم 99 من بين
الركاب ، وتم
تطعيم 100 من أفراد الطاقم
وأخبروني أنهم  قالت
الكابتن كيت مشوج
إنها كانت لحظة عاطفية بالنسبة
لهم للإبحار
من فورت لودرديل يوم السبت ، لقد
صدمتني حقًا على الرغم من أننا أسقطنا جميع
الخطوط عندما
خرجنا من الرصيف مع ضيوفنا
على متن الطائرة لأن
ذلك بدا كذلك  من الطبيعي أنه جعل
الأشهر الخمسة عشر الماضية
قليلًا من الحلم
وليس كابوسًا على الإطلاق لأننا
أتيحت لنا الفرصة للقيام بأشياء على متن
السفينة لم نكن لنستطيع القيام بها
إذا كنا  في الخدمة ، نعم الآن هنا
على سطح المسبح ، يمكنك
أيضًا أن ترى أنه لا يوجد الكثير من الأشخاص
يتجولون حول الكثير من الكراسي الفارغة ،
علامة أخرى
على السعة المخفضة على متن السفينة ،
يمكن أن تستمر السعة المخفضة
لعدة أشهر وفقًا لـ  الرئيس التنفيذي
ريتشارد فاين
في مقابلة أخبرنا أن البروتوكولات قد
تتطور بمرور الوقت مع استمرارنا في
الخروج
من الوباء ، وقال إن هذه
هي أول سفينة تغادر
من ميناء أمريكي منذ أكثر من 15 شهرًا ،
إنه يفضل القيام بذلك بشكل صحيح بدلاً من القيام بذلك  بسرعة